hello everyone how's everybody
uh welcome to rational science but today
we're not in germany i'm in south
america on vacation
and we're going to have to do it from
over here so
i would appreciate anyone letting me
know if
you can't hear me or you can't see me or
the transmission is choppy okay please
let me know i'd really appreciate that
meanwhile i'll continue and we're going
to start with some of the subjects of
related to extinction
here we have a situation today that
inflation is eating away
at salaries
which is essentially what my theory i'm
saying that that's exactly what's going
to happen the uh salaries are going to
be are going to become uh less valuable
as time goes by
and at some point they're going to be
worth
less all the way to worthless
so uh i think that's what's going to
happen and here's a couple
bit of news there
okay thank you
uh here's a um
a bit of news that came out of uh one
article out there you'll see several out
there so i haven't mentioned where this
came from but it says inflation now
running at 6.2 per year has quickly
become the dominant economic trend
okay biden said over the summer that a
spurt of inflation was likely to be
temporary stemming from the coveted
pandemic four months later inflation is
getting what
worse
okay
now they might fix that temporarily but
i'm saying that this can be a trend a
long term trend where the worker the
salaried person is going to be
getting less and less for his work and
that's not really a big problem it
doesn't really matter if he gets less
for his work the question is whether he
can make it to the end of the month
and it says there there's not a lot
biden can do about it okay root causes
semiconductor shortage massive new
spending on goods that's consumed
consumers stay home and a dirt of
truckers to move goods out of ports
towards their destinations
consumer confidence in this the lowest
level in 10 years lingering covid could
be part of the gloom there are still a
near record 10.4 million open jobs
and workers are quitting at record rates
a sign that they have better
opportunities elsewhere
like you know at home doing uh
maybe youtube stuff everybody wants to
set up a little shop
where he uh receives a check every month
for ads or whatever okay
and so we have a problem because you
have all these jobs opening all these
job openings and
nobody's going into them
the job market remains white hot leaving
inflation is the only real skunk at the
party fiscal spending probably isn't the
main cause of inflation but if it's
flooding the economy with money and
pushing up demand for scarce goods it
could at least be contributing
so yeah uh the question is whether uh
another
round of um
you know handouts from the government
will that just fuel inflation i mean it
might solve a lot of people's problem
especially the poor people uh but will
that uh just create a new round of
inflation of
devaluation of your
uh value of your salary
and i think that's the bottom line
so one of the things to think about is
that that's what i'm saying that's going
to happen the economy is going to
collapse
because money will be no more why will
money will be no more because
over time you're going to have a
devaluation of money to the point where
the worker doesn't make it to the end of
the month
okay and at that point everybody's going
to come out you're going to break
windows they're going to light
fires on tires and whatever there could
be a big mess out there that's what i
think is going to happen
and parallel to that you got something
else going on and that's uh this the war
between
it's a cold war now between
russia and the united states and china
and the united states
the united states being the big empire
trying to
expand its influence in regions where
it's meeting up with these uh two other
giants
okay one is in ukraine that's the map up
there
ukraine essentially
owns the western half
and russia uh owns a little less than
what i showed there but the other region
that is there uh a lot of russians live
there and they're they are pro-russian
they are not
pro-ukrainians
so that more or less gives you an idea
how the map of ukraine is divided and
the important part there is that a
little island on the lower right you
know that's the crimea and there was a
big war in the 1850s
over there
russians fought against the turks
british and the french who were on the
side of the turks at the time
but uh
you know irrespective of what happened
those days uh crimea
has belonged to the soviet union when
the soviet union broke up it went to
ukraine hoping that ukraine would stay
within the orbit of russia
that didn't happen very well you know
ukraine poland and uh some of these
other countries uh want to be on the
western side
and so russia had no other choice but to
take over what it considers a military
strategy militarily strategic point
which is that little island there that's
where it's got its
uh fleet okay
and um
on the bottom we see a little island
there right off the coast of china and
that's taiwan
okay and china wants that little blue
island and maybe there's going to be a
little bit of fighting over that island
the question is going to be
be whether it's going to be a little bit
or a big bit okay that's the question
there
is it going to stop at a conventional
war
which is likely it's going to lead to
war
and
or will it be
really go one step further and go to
nuclear war okay
so i think these are the issues of today
and those are the ones that are probably
going to take us to the end of the world
and it's going to be inflation the fact
that the workers are going to be losing
real value in their salaries they won't
make it to the end of the month and at
some point it's not even going to be
worth going to work
and on the other you have these military
uh confrontations
cold war
uh taiwan maybe one of them i don't have
a third one will appear but
right now it looks like it's ukraine and
taiwan
so keep those two regions in your head i
think they they're gonna have a
a big impact on the future of
not only man but on your personal future
okay things on the other side of the
planet might influence your own
uh life
okay
okay some of the issues people brought
up primarily related to homosexuality
apparently uh it's a subject that a lot
of people are
talking about these days because we see
a lot of it suddenly it came out of the
closet so to speak it's popular it's out
there and people have opinions about it
strong opinions by the way okay here's a
couple opinions okay one file says
there's a correlation between mother's
diet
he suggests vegetarian
and the probable uh gender of their
child
yeah i guess uh if you eat more veggies
you get a female
perhaps the mother's diet also affects
sexuality
you know gender identity
okay okay it's interesting uh opinion
could it be uh is it possible that what
we eat
uh determines
uh
not only uh
what kind of kid you're gonna have but
also the orientation of that kid
is this uh
something related to the environment to
what we eat what is it related to all
this uh homosexuality has there always
been homosexuality all around us and we
just suppressed it
and kept it inside the closet is is that
what's happened
or is there something new going on where
suddenly you have more and more people
who are coming out of the wombs
as homosexual
i think that's the issue so again it's
the issue of nature versus nurture okay
one fellow says along the same line most
gays are in prison
and are environmentally gay
well i don't know about that uh i think
this fellow knows very little about
prison and even less about homosexuality
uh in prison you know uh you don't see
gays
very few gays and the first thing they
do is
look for cover they they look for
protection a lot of people want to kill
them in prison and most uh people not
not most people want to kill them but
most people i'd say half and half half
of them tolerate them and half of them
have problems with them okay they don't
like them
and gays know that so what they do they
try to ask for some kind of protection
that's one issue
the other issue is that um
you know they don't do it openly okay
they don't uh
uh sell their wares out there so to
speak okay
and yeah we had a
few in our prison and they went around
one guy even slept with another asked to
be sleeping with him in one of the uh
rooms and they let him and they did
their thing in there you know
uh most of them didn't care most people
didn't care
but uh you know i had an anecdote where
one guy wanted to kill one of these guys
simply because he was homosexual
so uh no no most people in prison are
not gay in fact i would say the opposite
most homosexual people never make it to
prison in fact today i think if you ask
me at least you know i'd say the world
is turned upside down a lot of rich
people are gay go to san francisco i
used to live there in
sunnyvale and you go to san francisco a
lot of people are rich there and they
are homosexual that that's like the
homosexual capital or at least used to
be homosexual capital of the world
and a lot of people live there that are
rich and they are homosexual so
i don't know about this going to prison
no and another thing you know i i like
to mention to people people think that
you know you get a prison the first day
you get raped
and they say oh i'm going to get gang
raped in fact they made a movie about
that
but
that's all nonsense that's all uh i
think government propaganda so that you
behave because you'll be raped the first
day you go to prison you know
no it doesn't happen uh quite the
contrary in fact
just imagine
there's a little gang in there there are
a bunch of gangs by the way
you think the
head of the gang would tell his buddies
hey here comes a new
uh inmate i think i'm going to rape him
what do you think his buddies would
think of him
you think they would say oh that's our
leader
now they would wonder a lot about him
you know
now it's the other way around uh uh it's
a macho world over there it's all alpha
people more or less in there you know
you don't find uh homosexuals in there
and the few that are there they take
care of themselves because they could be
in trouble with who knows who someone
might approach him just punch him in the
nose
you know
okay another fella says
same-sex relationships can have
biological children of their own through
such things as artificial insemination
or surrogate mothers a heterosexual
couple isn't a requirement to have
children
well yeah of course we all know that but
the issue is you need a man and a woman
you need a an egg and a sperm
and you don't get egg and sperm from two
guys you don't get egg and sperm from
two women
that's the point okay so yeah they have
to go outside of the matrimonia of the
partnership whatever you want to call it
uh in order to have killed kids or adopt
you know but
they won't be able to have two women
can't have children two men can't have
children
and so the question is
uh just i throw this question to you
if we have more and more homosexuality
on the planet let us assume it's
increasing right
if it increases
that's a way of stopping reproduction
because the only way they're going to
reproduce is by getting to the other sex
momentarily going to sperm bank whatever
right
uh but
even in that case
do you think a homosexual couple
whether female or male will decide to
have
10 children
so
one of the issues there is whether maybe
mother nature
instituted homosexuality at the end of a
species lifetime
to stop reproduction is that a mechanism
mother nature has in store
in other words is it deterministic
or is it uh
like a lot of these people think uh that
it's something environmental something
that you eat
uh you know free will
is it
are you born that way are you nurtured
that way yeah
nature versus nurture are you born that
way
are you born heterosexual
or did
something someone train you to be it
they educated you and say you got to
look at girls
you can't look at
guys
is that the way it works or was it
something like innate it's something
inside you
you know so these are things you got to
ponder you know
whatever applies to you applies to the
homosexual so if you were born
heterosexual you're attracted by women
male attracted by women and vice versa
right
uh you got to think of homosexual in the
same way these guys are just attracted
to a female by nature it's just inside
them
they can't do anything about them at
least that's the way i look at it i
don't think uh these people were
educated to be like that
and to answer some of these
questions that come up here
you know i'll answer them in a second
here why do people stop being gay though
most changed their orientation within 13
years
the xk phenomenon is very real i know
for merely
gay men who suddenly stopped and started
pursuing women
and hetero pornography
okay people usually just say oh they're
secretly gay which is a coat
it doesn't help that we can't step into
these people's shoes
and along the same line japhel says
says lots of people get out of their
hormones in other words they go from
being a
homosexual to i don't know to a gorilla
suddenly he's got this
tarzan
stuff in him
[Laughter]
uh i don't think so i i don't i don't
believe that gay man can change any more
than you can change uh being
heterosexual if you're heterosexual do
you think tomorrow you're gonna say well
today i think i'm gonna try same-sex
do you think it works that way i mean
that you're actually truly genuinely
attracted by
your same sex do you think that changes
overnight that you just slept and had a
bad dream or something wake up say hey i
think i'm going to go after my same kind
you think it works that way
i mean would you do you want
to do that
would you desire to do that
and then the question for the game has
the same thing you know he he says
first do you think he really changed
er i mean assuming he tells you he
changed you know most most don't even
tell you that but the question is do you
even think he wants to change
i mean do you really think that he's got
it inside him he he can't do anything
about it it's like he's attracted to a
guy instead of a female because he's got
again like a female brain
and that's all i can tell you i mean you
know i'm not an expert on that all i can
tell you is what i've read out there and
that's that the brains of homosexuals
have been you know they they cut them up
and they studied the certain sizes where
love is produced inside the brain they
found them to be very similar to the
females not the males
so
i don't know that's some a factor you
gotta research if you're interested in
the subject
okay
almost out there same
sort of issue men do overrate their
masculine their own masculinity
look into a book called men against fire
by
mr marshall over three quarters of the
soldiers in world war ii refused to fire
at the enemy even when under direct
threat of death
uh well first of all i don't know if
that's
true i'm not sure if mr marshall
counted all the soldiers there you know
and said yeah three quarters 75 percent
decided not to shoot
then i don't know if this is related to
uh
macho culture uh the fact that
males in general
did the war through most of history
right yeah that's true
uh and does that make you does that have
anything to do with homosexuality or
or
or
lesbianism does it have anything to do
with more testosterone
uh more more estrogen does it have
anything to do with that or is this just
an issue of tradition of again free will
not determinism but free will the fact
that a lot of these uh people
you know they're sent into a war zone
and now they have to shoot at the enemy
and to say that
first of all that they're macho because
they're there i don't know the second
one is
you know uh the guy uh has to shoot at
someone coming down
well it's either him or or it's either
him or me you know it's
what do you think he's gonna do
and i'm not sure about uh these people
three quarters not shooting
i don't believe that either you know i
think uh
if that were true nobody would die in
the war okay very few would die no i
think uh people shoot they're told to
shoot they told them that's the enemy
hear the enemies rushing towards your
bunker or whatever what are you gonna do
you're gonna say no i'm not gonna shoot
him because he's a human being
no you're going to shoot him down that's
what you're going to do
just uh
you know a knee-jerk
sort of thing you know
okay another fella says
well it is known that girl gymnasts
start their menstrual cycle later than
other girls
okay
so being physically strenuous has
something to do with lowering estrogen
okay here i can tell you i looked at
three articles these are three uh
statements from three different articles
okay and one says there were no
significant pubertal uh
increase of estrogen levels in female
gymnasts during their pre uh
peripubertol development indicating a
low amount of fat mass in female elite
gymnasts another one says the present
study found no significant difference in
resting testosterone levels between the
gymnasts and the controls despite the
large amount of training these gymnasts
were involved in
and then third one says women who are
elite athletes or who exercise
excessively on a regular basis
are at a risk of developing athletic
amenorrhea
causes are thought to include low levels
of body fat and the effect
effects of exercise related
hormones on the menstrual cycle
okay so
whether
they really have uh
more estrogen less estrogen i'm not sure
uh that's the case
but uh you know again it's it's it comes
down to what people believe not so much
what
is objective
and so all i can do is tell you do
quite a bit of research and don't hang
on to whatever confirms your theories
try to find someone who
uh you know has um
made a study against your theory so that
you have something to compare against
something you someone that you can fight
against and not be so comfy with your
own you know beliefs
okay let's move on to the second segment
we're gonna do a little bit of physics
here
and i'm gonna start with a recap okay
here it is uh we have uh
we've been doing distance
we've been doing force
uh
mass acceleration
and the first thing i want to mention
just to reinforce that is that the
distance of
physics separation is not the same thing
as the distance traveled of mathematics
very very important
to keep that in mind
mathematics only has distance traveled
the what they do they unroll the
measuring tape and they measure how many
meters how many uh yards how many
kilometers
miles whatever
so distance uh when when the
mathematician says distance he means
distance travel displacement movement uh
change of position of location whatever
there's motion
okay that's not the distance of physics
which is a static concept which is a
separation between two objects this
traveled is one object that moves
away from a given
an arbitrary starting point
force uh
in
newton's second law right force equals
mass times acceleration that's push
okay again you're partying from a point
and moving forward okay and what is that
mass times the acceleration you're
pushing okay
and it's a dynamic concept on the other
hand uh newton's uh gravitational law
those those two laws by the way were
ascribed to uh
newton even though he doesn't deserve uh
the first one
more or less the sacrament again more or
less he he didn't come up with a
gravitational constant g he just said
you know uh it's because of masses that
we're being attracted that's all he said
it's a description he he never had an
explanation
and so the second uh
equation there force equals uh
gravitational constant g mass 1 mass 2
over distance squared that's a pull
force okay and that's a static
concept
actually it's not pull it's it's a
tension
because what you're talking about is two
masses
mass one mass two separated by a given
distance that's all you're talking about
there and so that separation of the two
masses is what gives you the force at
that location only
if that one of the two masses moves a
gazillions of an inch
uh all bets are off suddenly you have um
uh
suddenly you have a different weight
which is a different force
okay that that's a that's an equation
for weight essentially because you're
talking about gravity pulling down on
some object one mass in this case would
be the earth the other mass mass two
could be anything else could be even the
moon for all we know so whenever you're
talking about this equation you're
talking about two objects and separated
by a given
gap
uh separation
okay and so that
equation really is a equation of tension
i'm saying what you have there is
tension not force
and tension no it is not a force as the
mathematicians have always said for the
last 400 years
tension is nobody wins the tug of war
uh force
you have only two forces push and pull
and quantum mechanics they invented two
more the the strong force and the weak
force we don't know what those are but
they seem to be very similar to push and
pull because the weak force is an upward
force and the gluon you know the
uh strong force is an attracting force
it keeps two quarks together
so again we have push and pull so the
mathematicians have not invented
anything whatsoever under the sun we
still have qualitatively only two forces
push and pull that's it there's no more
tension is neither tension means that
you stretch the rubber band to the
maximum it doesn't stretch anymore no
matter what you do
so essentially at that point you can
treat it as an object made of a single
piece
okay
let me repeat that
you stretch it so much that it's almost
an object made of a single piece
and at that point you have no no motion
whatsoever there is no motion the two
objects are just static they're sitting
there waiting for something to happen
okay so tension
no motion it's a static concept that's
why it doesn't fall under force which is
a dynamic concept means something move
one way or the other push or pull
i have we got that okay because the
mathematicians out there they say no no
but we studied and we memorized the
stuff in college at the monastery
yeah sorry
qualitatively no there's uh we have a
difference between tension and pull
first of all and tension and force
because force is what an influence that
can change the motion
and that's not what tension does tension
doesn't change the motion that's what it
doesn't do okay it's what an action
reaction pair of forces but they talk
about forces again this definition is
when you get in the dictionaries okay
conceptually from a physical point of
view tension is a tight game no one wins
the tug of war everybody's pulling and
at that point at some point you stretch
it to the limit and that's tension
you're in a static situation you have a
certain distance
betw uh separation between the two
objects
measured by you know you can say well
the that separation
is a synonym of the stretching maximum
stretching of the rubber band string
rope whatever you got in between them
wire
coaxial
okay and then we went into mass okay
mathematics what do we have mass is
equal to weight
there is no difference in mathematics uh
between mass and weight because they
never found a way of
distinguishing between them the way we
determine mass is by weighing we don't
count atoms see if we counted atoms you
could say well mass is the quantity of
matter and weight is what we get on the
you know once we put it on the scale
that's not the case we put mass on the
scale that's how we determine mass
that's why it's measured in kilograms
supposedly weight is measured in newtons
but nobody talks about newtons everybody
talks about mass kilograms weight
kilograms or pounds pounds bushels bush
or whatever
that depends on you know what
unit you want to use
and unfortunately there's like seven
definitions of mass in mathematics and
they just live with them and continue on
with as if nothing and i showed the
other day there's like four definitions
of weight again everybody just uses
these things they say
we haven't agreed
who cares if you agree i mean this is a
question of science in science we do not
agree we either we fight for our
definitions and not everybody can have
the same definition okay
you have your definition you have to
defend it against the tax
that's the way it works there is no
consensus no democracy no authority in
science
okay one person says and i'm sorry
this is uh
again uh
well yeah this one person said says you
don't understand weight
okay
educate me let's see he says objects
don't have weight in free fall
aha
they only have weight on contact meaning
you know if it hits a scale then it has
a weight according to this fellow that's
what he learned at the monastery
mass is a detached approximation for
weight
okay let's find out let's see if this
fellow
is right okay yes even in the ballpark
okay here we have what is location
specific okay location and weight are
static concepts you have wait for a
given location only
you have a different weight in a
different location you have a given way
for a given location only weight does
not require contact which is what this
file is arguing here okay
measurement is not an activity of
science science we don't measure
anything therefore there has to be no
contact we don't use our hands
or elbows or head or you know our body
to contact something no we use our brain
we use our mind okay
in sense we do not place the astronaut
on a scale to determine whether he has
weight
in sense we conceptualize weight
the astronaut has weight whether we
weigh him or not
okay
do you think that astronaut on the lower
right there do you think he has weight
at a given distance from the earth
well yeah he has weight
is it because we put a scale underneath
him and he has contact with a scale and
he uh pushes down on that and says okay
you weigh 100 pounds here and you weigh
50 pounds over here and 150 over there
no we don't do that we we don't have to
do that we know he has weight at that
location he has a different weight a
different location we don't have to know
the value in science there are no
observers in science okay and here uh we
show this gentleman that uh no we do not
have con need contact at all here it is
uh here's the weight of the moon
it's 7.35 10 to the 22 kilograms that's
how much the moon weighs
is it because we uh we put the moon on a
scale somehow
is that how we determine that it weighs
that many kilograms
i don't know if you can find a scale
that big
enough you know and uh i'm not sure what
kind of contact you used to figure out
uh you know
what the moon weighs
no this was a calculated value okay and
so we do not have to have contact with
the moon at all okay
and in fact if the moon moves a little
bit here you see it okay you can see
that uh since the earth is uh
first of all not a completely uh round
sphere it's an oblate okay it's a
sparrow
a spheroid and uh it does change
its uh shape as the moon rose around it
as mr newton discovered okay so that's
something we owe mr newton but you can
see that you know the moon weighs
differently as soon as it moves just uh
an inch around the earth
okay so the moon doesn't always have the
same weight okay uh the way they should
really do that if they could you know is
give
different
weights for different locations and they
could probably do that with the uh
laser
pointer the laser what is it the uh
laser ranging experiment that they have
out there because they can
gauge the distance from the moon to the
earth and that can give them a good clue
of what the moon weighs at different
locations they need that distance okay
okay
so today we're gonna do
work what is work
okay anybody have any idea what work is
out there
well i'll tell you what work is here it
is that's my definition what the new
generations don't have
now how's that for a definition
i guess that's got to do with extinction
not with physics okay and here you have
another one which i have what the new
generations won't
have
how's that for a definition for work
and how about this one uh this is a
better one maybe um
what the new generations don't want to
do
i mean how many people i mean they say
what they have 10 million jobs and
nobody's applying for them
that gives you a clue that
there is work out there but either it's
not well paid
people are thinking that it's not worth
their trouble
maybe the guy lives with his mother or
his folks
and he's toughing it out maybe i don't
know selling something on the streets or
whatever or maybe on the internet and so
he doesn't want a
job that's going to take up all of his
time especially so he says look you know
i value my time what am i going to get
extra if i actually go out there work
and get a salary a devalued salary right
is that worth my while or should i just
continue uh doing what i'm doing now
whatever it is right
and live at mama's
and or my girlfriends or whatever and
you know just live alone
i think a lot of uh
people in the new generation are
selecting that that option right there
they're going with that option
okay but let's see what it is in physics
okay it says work force times the
distance through which it acts
okay so we have a force
and it's going to be applied through a
certain distance
and there you have the one from
dictionary.com says the transference the
transference of energy
equal to the product of the component of
a force that acts in the direction of
the motion of the point of application
of the force and the distance through
which the point of application moves
the transference of energy we're going
to be transferring energy whatever that
is
i guess we'll find out in a minute here
uh what does wikipedia say well work is
the product of force and displacement
okay that's
sounds straightforward then it continues
work the energy transferred to or from
an object via the
application of force along a
displacement
again the
energy transferred
okay so there you see all these energy
thingies moving
from right to left
uh is that what force that what work is
just a bunch of
concepts being transferred i mean what
is this thing called energy
and again i always like to
introduce authority so that i can
convince you and persuade you and
convert you okay and so here it is we
have mr richard feynman he says it is
important to realize that in physics
today we have no knowledge of what
energy is
and yeah uh i can only tell mr feinman
that energy is not a what
energy is a concept
what is it the capacity the ability
whatever okay that's a concept
so you can't say you're going to
transfer energy like these people saying
or you know move energy around you can't
transfer concepts
so the first thing uh you we note is
that if work has something to do with
the transferring of energy we already
start off on the wrong foot this makes
no sense whatsoever in science okay
uh in physics
this has to do with mathematics
uh a uh a
an explanation a physical interpretation
in which they're moving concepts
and that's our first uh notion of
irrationality irrationality first notion
uh or first criterion uh movement of
concepts
it's called reification you are reifying
a concept and then pretending going
through the motions you know like the
mind
of moving it around
very scary stuff okay
yeah never do that uh they might put you
away
okay they should put all the
mathematicians who do that away okay you
can't transfer energy because energy is
a concept
and uh unless you have an object you
know you can transfer a tree you can
transfer a dog you can even transfer a
house you know some of these uh
prefabricated houses uh but you can't
transfer energy you can't transfer love
you can't transfer intelligence some
people apparently have you know but
in general i mean
okay so what is work well work is
performed when a body is moved against a
resisting force
okay so there you have the little man
he's pushing
and
in this case uh you have friction on the
ground you know maybe if that's a
refrigerator for example right it weighs
a lot so it's being pulled by gravity or
pushed by gravity or whatever gravity is
right but the point here is uh you get
friction and so the guy has to push
against that friction essentially okay
and so it's a work is force
uh times distance traveled and again
it's not distance it's distance traveled
we're talking about displacement here
okay there's motion
okay um
here we have um
a little breakdown of that so we have
work is equal to force times distance
traveled
what is force well we held that force is
equal to mass times acceleration
but what is acceleration well
acceleration has this change in velocity
over change in time and we don't have to
go into any more detail with that just
to say that
change in velocity has to
in bodies includes distance traveled
there is a distance traveled component
in velocity
okay
and uh what is that that's motion
so we have work is equal to mass times
motion which is that portion of uh
change in velocity
and what is the distance traveled that
we started out with their force times
distance traveled well you see its
motion as well
so we have our conclusion we have work
is equal the motion to the motion of
motion
in fact mass is also motion because what
is mass it's not the counting of atoms
we don't do it that way what we do is we
weigh it
and uh the mathematicians would like for
you to think of mass as a dynamic
concept because like in special
relativity if you accelerate mass at
near the speed of light you are pressing
down on the scale
a lot harder than if it's just standing
still
so
what happens is they say mass increases
so they have mass as a dynamic concept
because it's moving near the speed of
light and so it increases therefore is
also motion so i forgot one motion there
at the bottom i would have to say that
work is the motion of motion of motion
okay
that's a more correct way of stating so
what do you do when you go to the office
what do you do when you go to the rock
pile well you are doing a lot of motion
and nothing else
okay now you know what is uh work but a
bunch of motion
motion of motion of motion that's it
okay
but
here we have
another situation
what if
we take that equation okay and now we
turn it around and
put it in the vertical direction well
what we have is work is weight times
height remember what is weight that's
force what was force mass times
acceleration
and what they use that you always use
that force equals times
mass times acceleration
but now you're talking about weight and
that what is weight weight is a struggle
against gravity especially if you're
you know pushing pulling the box upward
you're pulling against gravity
or maybe gravity is pushing down on the
box some people like to do with
particles right okay either way
you're you're fighting against gravity
that's the point okay you're struggling
against gravity what is height well
that's the distance traveled that's the
displacement in this case it's a
vertical displacement okay so we have
work in this case it's no longer
sideways like it was before force equals
mass times acceleration now we're
supposed to use really newton's
gravitational law
right you would think because it's more
applicable to what we're doing here so
we would have to use the
uh force in the gravitational law which
is uh gravitational constant g mass 1
mass 2
divided by distance squared which is
essentially the distance between the box
and the center of the earth
what is that times height
because what is height it's again it's
not a single value what you're doing you
have a displacement upwards you're
moving the box upwards and so you're
going to look at how much you move them
say okay that's how much work i did
okay i hope that's clear
so we have two different types of work
we have one which is horizontal work
and one which is vertical work okay and
what i'm saying to you is uh i have no
problem with them using the mass times
acceleration
force for horizontal movement but we
have a problem when they don't use that
same when they don't use the
gravitational equation for upward
or even downward by the way because
going downwards just make it easier but
you still have the force of gravity one
way or the other so when you do it grav
vertically in other words perpendicular
to
a plane
cutting the center of the earth well
when you do it vertically like that you
have to use newton's
gravitational law
that's that's my
proposal i'm saying the mathematicians
never discovered that and they keep
using
force equals mass times acceleration for
everything okay
so why is that a problem well let me
show you
here we have a different situation we
have an inclined plane okay what happens
in an inclined plane now we have two
components we have a horizontal
component and a vertical component okay
here you have a little more than maybe
45 degrees more or less but you can see
what's happening here you have a
vertical compo vertical component and a
horizontal component
and now which equation are we supposed
to use i mean we have force equals mass
times acceleration that's going to be
for the horizontal segment how about the
vertical segment are we going to use the
gravitational law
g mass 1 mass 2 divided distance squared
distance between what between i guess
the ball and the center of the earth
separation
okay for any given point along that
curve
okay that's what we're talking about
remember force when you when you
calculate for force you're calculating
only one value
that value has only
is only
valid for the given distance that you
calculated
the next frame of the movie okay
you have a different distance now you
have to do the calculation all over the
again and calculate the force for the
new distance assuming the mass has
stayed the same and we will assume the
two masses are the same the separation
changes gravitational constant g is
again a constant so we don't change that
the only thing that's changing there is
the distance
okay
but the distance is upwards so you have
separation between the earth and the the
ball and you have different values for
every single location
okay
so you take all these values and you can
you know get your curve in mathematics
okay so what's the issue here well
this is more or less the situation okay
here it is all three of them put
together
uh no sorry this is just the explanation
here incline plane okay work is equal to
force times distance traveled okay but
what happens with a slanted surface that
has two components the horizontal and
the vertical well the vertical part you
should be using newton's gravitational
law okay work is equal to force times
distance traveled times cosine a where
did they get that well the cosine a
gives you the angle of that uh slant
there the slope of that curve assuming
that mountain that the fellow is pushing
the ball upwards on to uh assuming that
we're a completely straight line right
well you could calculate through the
cosine of a
what the value to give at each point
okay
so what happens when a is equal to zero
you have cosine of zero and that's one
and that would give you a horizontal
that's if the guy rolled the ball or
pushed the ball sideways horizontally no
no upward motion but what happens when
you have it at an angle well they don't
use newton's gravitational law what they
do is they say well calculate the angle
okay
and just get the cosine of that angle
it'll give you that slope and that'll
give you the uh the work that you did uh
if you multiply it times force times
distance traveled
okay that's what how they do it that's
conceptually what they're doing but the
issue is they're not taking into
consideration
the
the gravity what they're doing is this
calculating an angle because that's
sufficient
for mathematics
uh the question here is what is
happening physically that's that's what
we want to
understand okay what is happening
physically is that you have two motions
a horizontal and a vertical one if you
did the vertical one alone you would
have to use newton's equation they don't
do that they use force times mass times
acceleration then they get confused
because you get people like einstein he
says i don't understand why force equals
mass times acceleration is equal to
force equals g mass 1 mass 2 divided by
distance squared which is essentially
the
principle of equivalence and he says
well i think they're very much similar
but i don't understand why
of course he's not going to understand
why because he doesn't he never did
qualitative stuff in his life
that's why he ended up with warped space
and
warped time and who knows what in other
words fourth dimension
no uh it's very simple under the rope
model i explained it the other day you
have a hydrogen atom whether it's
leaving the earth or coming towards the
earth at a given distance
force equals mass times acceleration
which is the push force going outwards
is equal to
force equals gravitational constant g
mass 1 mass 2 over distance squared
which is the pull force of you know all
the ropes at that given point
at that given distance
or location
okay uh so
there we have it all three of them put
together okay we have the
guy on the bottom he's pushing his uh
i guess his refrigerator
pushing it sideways okay that's work
equals force times distance traveled no
problem there uh we have a problem with
the guy on the right because they use
that same equation essentially and they
should be using the
um
gravitational equation that's what i'm
saying
again
versus distance traveled and what do you
do when you roll something in an
inclined plane well uh somehow we have
to make use of these two equations and
turn it into uh in order to understand
physics right uh so that we we would
have to use a combination of these two
equations to understand the physics of
it is that what they've done is they
said just calculate the angle the cosine
of a and you'll be okay you'll know what
the work is yeah that's great for
mathematics it doesn't give us any
insight in physics
okay so that's
i guess what you can say is uh the
bottom line
uh we're interested in physics not in
math okay here are the conclusions for
today okay we have uh math is
these are their
uh versions
work is equal to force times distance
traveled times cosine of a okay work
uses newton's second law force equals
mass times acceleration work does not
incorporate the law of gravity okay
and uh essentially it amounts to what
what is it uh push times motion times
motion what is push also motion so it's
uh motion times motion times motion
that's what work is in science we do it
a little differently that was a
mathematical
version okay science we do it a little
differently we say in physics there is a
gravitational component
okay so that you understand that you're
pulling against gravity no matter what
even if you
go horizontally you have to factor that
gravitational pull they never do it
because it's the same for anywhere on
earth essentially right so you know you
look at only the horizontal component
but keep in mind that you know the earth
every atom on earth is pulling on
whatever you're moving sideways okay
keep that in mind it doesn't go away and
the explanation is qualitative that's
what we're interested we're not
interested in uh in math in the numbers
that's all that these the mathematicians
are interested in uh we're interested in
the qualitative stuff we want to
understand what the mechanism
mechanism involves both second law as
well as the gravitational equation
that's known as physics okay we need an
explanation for what is actually
happening in that invisible world and
yeah you're going to eventually zero in
on the mechanism of gravity
and realize that it's a pull force some
kind of pull force you know and i always
say do this experiment at home always in
the presence of a trained relativist
okay just put your arms to your side
okay
and see if you think something is
pushing on your arms or you feel like
they're pulled
downwards by the by whatever gravity is
okay and yeah you'll feel that
you're being pulled it's easier to pull
down than it is to pull up okay why
because you're being pulled from the
bottom okay just like two magnets
you know
you're being you're not being you don't
feel that your hands are being pushed
from the outside you feel that something
is already pulling from the inside here
so this magnetism is some kind of pull
force and in a similar way okay and then
as an analogy only if you put your arms
to your side you feel that oh man
it feels a lot better when it goes down
why because something is pulling and
pull is easier okay
uh you're you're struggling you when you
pull your arms up you're again you feel
that something is actually pulling from
the bottom not pushing from the top okay
at least that's my experience maybe you
can tell me yours
okay uh let's go on with some of the
questions people raise some of the
issues here we have first one probably
he talks about the mathematical physics
method okay math fizz method
and he says they use careful observation
and experimentation to confirm or reject
a hypothesis
okay i'm not sure what
i mean a hypothesis is an assumption
what are you going to confirm
and what if you do confirm who confirmed
the home to yourself or to whom to your
boss
evidence against theories and laws are
searched for and studied closely
uh yeah evidence is what they use for
what for to persuade to convince people
and that's known as religion so yeah we
don't use evidence in science
but they apparently use it in this
mathematical physics method okay and
theories they don't have any theories
because math has no theories whatsoever
math is only a descriptive
discipline they only describe
and
mathviz has attempted to give
explanations
to some of those equations and just
about every in fact every single
equation uh
related every single explanation related
to invisible entities is a ration every
single one there's not one that is
rational why because they do it all with
particles
and if you do with particles or waves
which are another way of saying
particles uh you're not going to be able
to explain how mother nature runs this
shock
okay
and there are no laws in science so yeah
mathviz method is
deals with laws whatever those are
apparently they've turned all these
equations and they call these equations
laws
that's what they
they think god made them or something
okay it says based on well-established
repeating patterns and regularities in
nature okay reproducible results are
required of experiments well yeah
here's uh
let me show you for a second here give
me a second
i'll do a
little experiment okay here's there's a
reproducible result okay i let go of the
ball okay falls to the floor i let go of
it again and again it falls again to the
table repeatable done it twice right
that's repeated you want three times
okay i'll do it one more time okay okay
so i did the experiment
uh 10 times 100 times a million times
does that mean you can explain
what caused the ball to fall down
to the floor and not to the ceiling
so no uh you know
in science we don't care about uh what
this uh
mathematical method proposes
reproducible results are not important
in case of failure no excuses are
acceptable yeah personal stories or
testimonials are not accepted as
evidence that's strange because they
introduce observation and observation
has a single purpose and that's tell
your personal story
okay you're your own anecdote
consistent and interconnected okay
argues from scientific knowledge it
turns out that uh we don't know what
knowledge is they never define the word
so we don't know what they mean when
they say knowledge okay
knowledge according to the definition is
justified through belief
there is no difference between knowledge
and belief
one people has one person believes that
god doesn't exist the other one knows
that god doesn't and so you figure out
which one is correct and again you find
out that they both believe
okay use a vocabulary that is well
defined and is in wide usage by
co-workers okay first of all well
defined there's nothing well defined in
mathematical physics uh
you get words like energy we just found
out that mr feinman says he doesn't have
a slightest clue what it is we have
seven definitions of mass
what was it for of weight
they don't know what time is no one can
define the word time in such a way that
they can use it consistently and apply
it because
they just want to use the numbers in an
equation which has nothing to do with
the definition that they put out there
okay so
so they have all these words like wave
and so on and they turn them into
physical objects that are not well
defined at all in fact they're not
defined let alone well okay
and then wide uses that's got to do with
democracy that's raising your hands and
saying oh we're going to use it here at
our club we're going to use it in our
congregation
well yeah so you know that doesn't make
it right you can use the flat earth that
could have white usage that doesn't make
it so
okay so yeah it doesn't matter
we don't use democracy we don't use wide
usage we don't use voting okay none of
that
applies in science
convinces us by appeal to evidence well
again we convinced has to do with
persuading we don't convince we don't
pursue it we don't convert not in
science that's in religion so you're in
the wrong place and again evidence is
what you use to persuade people to
change their opinions so we don't use
evidence whatsoever evidence has no
place in science it only has place in
religion it only triggers or or targets
uh belief opinion
peer review again we don't do peer
review uh
the only thing we do
is we criticize
from uh the scientific method to see if
it's rational and if it's irrational for
example if they convert concepts into
physical objects and begin to move them
around like transferring energy or
moving a wave then we have a problem
with that and that's when it dies that's
the only review we do other than that we
don't care about the uh in fact quite
the quite the contrary we
we uh accept all kinds of ideas out
there we allow them all to every person
to express his ideas once he passes the
rationality part okay he's got to make
sure that he doesn't turn concepts such
as energy
into objects or you know uh vortex into
a physical object or ether into a
physical object none of those things
are allowed in science okay so
but that's the extent of the so-called
peer review it's called challenging the
uh
the uh assumptions okay
and yeah there are no experts in science
that's known as authority uh uh
the only thing i can recommend all
people who follow this mathematical
method they probably should become
catholics and just bow down to uh you
know the vatican or whatever you know uh
you'll find experts over there
in science we have no experts
progresses as time goes on more and more
is learned well obviously that doesn't
apply to mathematical physics because
the math of methviz method they haven't
learned anything for example about uh
gravity in the last 400 years not one
bit they haven't learned anything
whatsoever about electricity they
haven't learned anything whatsoever
about magnetism or the workings of the
atom so
we don't know what they learn they learn
absolutely nothing right now they have
only irrational explanations and if they
have irrational explanations
what can we say that they learned
i mean they haven't learned anything
absolutely nothing and i'm not
exaggerating here the invisible world is
totally unknown
or like mr feynman said i wish i would
have put that up there he said we don't
understand anything we cannot explain
anything
of especially you know the quantum world
the world that we that the unseen the
world of the unseen untouchable
they don't understand that because again
they don't deal with objects they deal
with equations they can describe what's
going on there with the visible stuff
and they
imagine it's mediated by particles right
or concepts
but
they don't really know what's going they
cannot explain to you a mechanism they
cannot give you a physical
interpretation okay
okay here we have uh
saint phil says
pseudoscience he says mathematical
physics falls under the pseudoscience i
guess he says starts with a hypothesis
looks only for evidence yeah i guess
that's called qualifies as pseudoscience
when you look for evidence you're
talking about
really
religion you could call it pseudoscience
fine no problem
little or no experimentation yeah we
don't do experiments in science so i
guess
if you do any kind of experimentation
you're doing pseudoscience
experimentation the only reason for
experiment experiments is to convince
yourself of something and to convince
someone else of something in science we
don't care about that we care that you
give us an explanation of how the
invisible world of mother nature works
that's where
uh
that's what the purpose of science is if
you can do it with experiments if you
can do it by having a bad dream at night
we don't care we don't care how you got
to that we just want the explanation
okay we want you to give us a rational
explanation of how mother nature does
gravity
uh magnetism electricity workings of the
atom etc
conflicting evidence is ignored uh yeah
i mean you know
again we don't use evidence in science
so anyone who uses evidence is doing
pseudoscience in any way shape or form
personal stories or testimonials are
relied upon for evidence yeah i guess
that's that's what it is anyone who
relies upon for evidence
uh is doing again religion okay and yeah
personal stories because they introduced
the observer and they constantly say
well we observed this that's where how
they start they say we observe this in
the lab and yeah that that amounts to uh
uh testimonial we don't care what you
observe in fact they're observing
invisible stuff they're saying they
observed two particles at uh up one part
of what two places at once
they observe big bang you know they
observe all this stuff and you know and
those are personal stories those are
testimonials
argues from ignorance absolutely
pseudoscience argues from ignorance and
that's mathematical physics right there
because they claim they know nothing
okay they have no explanations for how
this universe works okay
uh lack of scientific explanation is
used to support ideas absolutely no
scientific explanation no no rational
explanation
use especially invented terms that are
vague yeah they use like energy mass
time field wave they use words like that
uh ether
vortex you know they have a charge they
have all these words out there that they
invented that have no meaning they're
all concepts and they're treated as
physical objects so not only are they
vague but they're irrational completely
irrational attempts to persuade
absolutely that's what pseudoscience
does anything related to persuasion you
know convincing recruiting that's called
religion
no peer review
with checks or
verification
yeah
again in science we have no peer review
pseudoscience i don't know
i don't know if the uh
monks you know check each other out
i don't know that's something that matt
fizz has to answer and no progress
nothing new is learned as time passes
absolutely mathematical physics nothing
has been learned from through
mathematical physics in the last 400
years since newton uh galileo and so on
what have we learned i mean what can
they explain
can i mean is is warpage of time
an explanation for gravity which is the
official version is a particle at two
places at once is that an explanation
for what's happening in the quantum
world is that a rational explanation
so if those are irrational explanations
are very clear-cut that any rational
person should look at that and say well
this is absurd well then what have we
learned
what can these people explain to you
especially when mr feinman says
and he's a guru he's a nobel prize
winner he's
revered by all these uh
mechanics right if he tells you that
we have no explanation we've given up on
explaining meaning mathematical physics
right physicists they've given up on
explaining and giving you um
physical interpretations for what's
going on in that
invisible intangible world of mother
natures
okay here we have another fellow and he
says
here we have in fact an example says
energy is change over time
yeah the only thing that's fast answer
is how do you transfer change i mean you
carry it with your hands you pick it up
with tweezers how do you transfer change
that's the only thing he's got to
answer so if that's what energy is well
you got to do is
explain how you transfer it okay no
mathematical equations we want to see a
physical interpretation for the transfer
of energy what did you do okay
now the file says
says
unfalsifiable means there is no way to
test it to know whether it is true or
false
well true or false are opinions
so again unfalsifiability popper's
criteria right for science
is absolute nonsense because that has to
do with belief
it has nothing to do with science he has
to do holy 150 with religion has to do
with opinion
i mean is god true or false
i mean period i mean that's what you got
to put there and if you have your
opinion i have my opinion well then we
have no unfalsified be a lady we have no
way of falsifying whatever you propose
okay
so yeah we don't we don't care because
even if you have a way of falsifying it
all you did was give you us your opinion
you say oh i can falsify this
okay yeah if you falsified you did it to
yourself uh maybe the pope has a
different opinion on whether you
falsified god you know or the angels or
whatever or space-time
okay uh here we have um another
following he says
in the tension of gravity newton's
equation what does g represent
gravitational constant g okay this is
the value that has been calculated for
more than 200 years yeah seeking and
researching accuracy and precision
however there's still no explanation for
how it works this number la la la what
does it represent what does it mean
okay uh
this is beyond the scope of youtube uh i
have explained it in my book very in
quite a bit of detail in fact so all i
can tell you is uh if you get a hold of
my book from a friend or whatever well
then you'll see it there okay
uh it's too lengthy to present here okay
so yeah i do have an explanation for
what that number in the units represent
i think i explained that in quite a bit
of detail i don't think you can explain
in more detail than that so um
all i can do is tell you
uh go look at the book not that i'm
trying to sell you a book i'm just
saying that's where i put it okay
and that's
too complicated to explain here
sorry
so you'll have to take a rain check from
me on that one
fella says uh why does don't the ropes
get knotted together
okay
well they don't get knotted together
first because he's got the wrong
criterion okay
object is not that which you can see or
touch okay so that's what he wants touch
he's talking about touch there okay no
that's not what an object is a rope is
an object because it has shape okay do
you see the shape you see something
there hopefully uh in front of my nose
there okay
okay so uh
you should be able to
figure that one out uh the criterion
that you're choosing is what's wrong
okay what's irrational because if we
tell you that the rope cannot be seen or
touched that it's a fundamental that the
thread that makes you up the rope is a
fundamental entity that cannot be seen
or touched
it's nonsense to say why can't two ropes
touch each other well because they
cannot be seen or touched
what part don't you understand
why can't you see the air
i mean that's the same question i can't
see the ear well why can't you see the
ear
i don't god didn't give me the right
eyes i guess
why can't you touch the moon i mean i
can't touch the moon maybe if i were an
astronaut i could go out there but i
can't touch the moon so does that mean
that uh
we have a problem that the moon is not
an object because of that
because i can't touch it
in fact uh i don't know some people
might ask uh why can't you touch uh that
tape on the other side of the planet
well because
you know it's just not available to me
that's why
and this is more or less the same thing
you say well no but here we have them
touching
well for that you got to come up with
the word touch you need to know what the
word touch means
uh you know you haven't given us a
definition of the word touch
and i'm sure i can destroy whatever
definition you put up there so uh i'll
wait for your definition of touch how's
that is that a fair game
okay
i'll take the challenge you define touch
and i'll tell you how they why they
avoid touching
getting knotted
okay and a final issue singularity
doesn't does mean it
secondary does mean it came from nothing
doesn't mean i guess he meant to say we
can't trace back before that he's
talking about the big bang big bang does
not say everything came from nothing
and that's the big problem that is
the fatal problem with big bang
because the big bang says
we we can go no further than the big
bang
and that's the problem because where did
the matter come from where did space
come from specifically space forget
about matter matter is easy to create
you know the issue how do you create
space how do you create nothing
that's what the challenge is and so what
these people are saying that suddenly
there was an explosion
explosion of what because you need to
have a foundation you have to have a
hypothesis you have to have something
before it explodes
and these people are trying to sell you
a whopper they say there was nothing
which is what space is
and suddenly it created space
so there was space and you created space
from absolutely
space
nothing
void vacuum
that's what they're saying so big bang
is is for people who you know with tiny
brains who who accept this nonsense as a
physical interpretation okay what
they've done is simply rewind the clock
back and they said look if galaxies are
all going away from each other in the
past they were closer together that's
what they do that's what big bang is all
about
and so what are they saying well they
say if you wind the tape
all the way to the beginning at some
point 13.7 13.8 billion years ago
you end up with a singularity what's a
singularity it's a mathematical
mathematical
nonsense called zero nothing zero volume
of what
in what
they say it's space that suddenly got
created space got created
from what
well we can't go that far well then you
don't have a rational theory we we won't
accept your theory until you can explain
that point you have to explain that
point you can't allude it you can't say
well that's unscientific
because we weren't there we didn't see
god make the singularity or whatever
you you have to explain because that's
what we want to know we want to know the
origin of matter and the origin of space
which is what supposedly the big bang
created from what what was there before
of course you need to put that before in
there
you can't elude that that's the fatal
problem with big bang you can't elude
the question
okay with that i'll see you next time
and that's gonna be i guess on sunday
uh am i right no i'm gonna see you on
wednesday we'll see you then bye bye